guys this is episode 5.
[Laughter]
it's the end of the day and we're punch
strong
5 11 on a tuesday afternoon 2-2 bottom
of the 9th
charlie let me ask you a question how do
you get it up at 4 11 in the afternoon
how do you get it up i ate a chocolate
chip dunker glad it was a it was a
chocolate chip cookie that was meant to
be dunked in coffee
online sparkling water here and it's not
doing the trick now had i got myself a
coffee i'd be all fired up and ready to
go so i'm operating purely on the
chocolate and the cookie
well coffee at 4 11 in the afternoon is
what i call a bad idea now why don't you
call a bad idea glitter had you had an
improper sleep experience after hours
my daddy told me that you need seven
hours between your last coffee and when
you go to bed otherwise you won't sleep
good and is your body a doctor and he is
he aware of all the things in the
universe and how they work and does he
have superior knowledge compared to you
or say uh someone else who it might also
be a doctor i don't know rob what do you
think what the [ __ ]
[Music]
guys this is uh episode five of the it's
always sunny in philadelphia podcast uh
we wanted to come out of the gates
wanted to come out of the gates hot for
that one
late in the day well we did guys listen
you were falling asleep on the couch
30 minutes ago yeah i'm an actor i don't
know
deep rob you've got to dig deep this is
the mania that we've been talking about
no no it's just no the mania is no you
don't it's just the entertainer in me
it's just the entertainer in him robert
don't just repeat everything i say and
stop repeating what he's saying yeah
talking to
you
all right all right episode five guys
gun fever
this one holds up well i'll tell you why
i like that violence still a thing
apparently yeah gun violence still a
thing i don't see anything from from the
first season in ten years but that one i
don't remember at all
shelley is incredible
who plays uh huang yeah in the episode
and uh by by the way he was supposed to
be korean that's why his name is hwang
when shelley auditioned we're like well
the character is only shelley it's got
to be this guy but we didn't change the
name we just decided to keep the name
even though but he is out of control
yeah very funny well he didn't know the
tone of the show neither did we we were
trying to find it and figure it out and
he was playing the honesty
well not only did he not know the tone
of the show he didn't know what the show
was and what i mean and granted it was
the first season but he also years later
didn't know that he'd done the show
because he came in and auditioned for a
totally different character yes
apparently having not known that he was
already a recurring character on on the
show correct correct outrageousness
and that too yes but we couldn't
remember that of course
it didn't make any sense we had to call
our casting director and say this guy's
already a recurring character in the
show
and he can't play tony because he can't
be two different people yeah although
although we have done that we have done
that that's true so i found that very
funny my favorite shelley desai story
though is that the season one
rap party yeah which is uh for those of
you who don't know at the end of the
season all the time should you have like
a little party at the end to celebrate
with the crew and everybody who was
involved in the making of the show
uh you know to basically celebrate all
of your achievements and uh you know pat
yourselves on the shoulder and just
because it was a bit but it's a big
thing when you're first starting out
because it feels like oh wow you wrapped
the show it's a party you're still young
enough and full of life that you want to
have fun yeah um you don't have to go
home to the stupid [ __ ] dogs that
can't walk themselves you know like you
want to go out okay and and drink and
you know enjoy your life it's nice for
the crew everyone's worked really hard
it's been a long time and it's just one
night to be like hey we did yeah we did
it yes we did we gotta do that let's let
loose together congrats everybody and
thank you for all your hard work that
type thing yeah and then everybody shows
up and it's at least back in the day
everybody would show up and it would be
nice
so rob uh shelley dusai yeah shelly
desai comes into the party the guy who
plays swang
you're the first person i think he sees
yeah i'm standing right next to you okay
i'm there for this yeah and and he comes
up to you and you're thinking he's
coming up to you because you guys worked
together and you know we were on the
show together yeah you're thinking he's
gonna come and be like oh hey what a
great time it was or something yeah
something like thanks for the job
shelley looks like but instead right
thanks for the game hey guys good to see
you again congratulations on the end of
the season we think he's gonna no that's
not none of that happened he walked up
to you i don't think he knew who the
[ __ ] you guys were and he said what
well where's the food
where's the food where's the food
and where's the food has stuck with me
for the rest of my life yeah so anytime
you walked up to the show's creator yeah
where's the food where's the friend
i didn't say hi nothing just just
where's the food
fair question where was the food but it
has become a running
listener at home this has become a
running joke with us anytime someone
orders food
i think five five ten minutes later
we'll look we'll look at each other and
say where's the food where's the food
where's the food where's the food this
is the first time we had uh gujinos yes
oh man uh's is the restaurant that if
you're a super fan you know exactly what
it is but gino's is the restaurant that
in this episode sweet d goes to with uh
what was rosenbaum's character's name
why am i forgetting colin colin i don't
think we say the name of the restaurant
but i remember when i was writing it i
don't know why but carla gugino came to
mind and i thought cugino's that's a
good so that name that restaurant is
actually named after the actress carla
gugina
now that location is in the herald
examiner which was william hurst
newspaper factory right his newspaper
was the herald examiner his factory was
in downtown los angeles and it had been
converted into a bunch of sets one of
which was a bar
that we dressed and so that's why i
passed the lobby looks like yeah sorry
and the lobby of that building was
cugino's oh my god i'd forgotten that
which we also used as the bank in the uh
episode where we popped our shirts off
to try to yeah yeah uh yes woo the bank
teller and then a bunch of other
locations were in that
sweet apartment yeah we shot all over
that [ __ ] uh degree and remember
every year they would say you got to
move out of there you got to move it
somewhere else because you're going to
tear it down and then they wouldn't tear
it down never did and then well they
have now have they yeah oh no they tore
down but they they kept the lobby oh so
we can still do gugino's no i think it's
like a condos or something and so i
think so
is done that's why we haven't shot there
in a while right because it doesn't
exist
that's uh that's sort of an end of an
era thing for me because i always really
enjoyed those episodes i mean the gang
dines out you know the whole episode
takes place
yeah i always like that set oh man
that's a bummer funny funny things
happen that's too bad that's too bad
because it was overly fancy for these
guys like it was
palatial
yeah yeah it was a sound issue right
because it was marble everywhere and
they wouldn't this particular episode
the sound is terrible like i'm off mic
after i do did we not when did we not
wear body mics was that seasoning we
must have always worn no there was a
year there was a season where we didn't
wear them really yeah then season one
surely do you remember the season where
we had a boom operator who was like he
must have allergies or was a coke addict
but like he always was like holding the
boom over your head he'd be like
and i'm like look if i'm hearing it
you've got to be my dad i'm i'm i dude i
i am constantly amazed at how often a
boom mic guy
will be the one who's making the most
noise
well they can't
what the [ __ ] are you whenever i see a
boom guy chewing gum are you [ __ ]
kidding me dude that's because that
person's hearing everything except
except himself or herself son of a [ __ ]
i hate that [ __ ] i don't like chewing
gum i just don't like it i don't like it
that's misophonia right misophonium
misophonia i do i do have misophonia i
do look it up that's long establishment
chewing drives that's a long style it
bugs me too i'll i'll admit it does yeah
yeah that makes me feel better about
this you're not alone in that just don't
smack your gum man don't smack it if
you're gonna insist on chewing it like a
[ __ ] cow just don't smack it you
[ __ ] jerks and definitely don't pop
it don't be popping and smacking you
smack and pop your gum you know you're
not we don't want to [ __ ] hear it we
don't want to hear it we've got our own
things going on it's like i'm thinking
about something but all i can hear is
you
[ __ ] you
[Music]
guys did you notice on the show we yell
a lot on it's always studying in
philadelphia
and and we yell over each other
well quite a bit yeah i mean that was
was part of the quote-unquote charm of
the show wasn't it you know which is
also why a lot of the reviews were like
i
don't like it because it's just people
yelling at each other and they're not
totally wrong and i think a lot of
people were like i like it because it's
people yelling at it because it's people
yelling at each other just like i do
with my friends in real life i talk over
them because i don't i have [ __ ] to say
yeah yeah yeah
i got a question for you guys um
rob hmm well let me take this charlie
charlie yeah okay good good what what no
i mean you started you're real man you
started with me i feel like i've asked
you a bunch of questions that i want to
start with charlie good uh he's also a
bigger star okay for now uh true it's
too late rob you're 44. yeah it's too
late buddy he's he's he's established
the door is closed buddy it's closing
it's closed it's close
that's close gene hackman
all right
i'm morgan freeman
i'm morgan freeman um charlie
how do you feel about guns
well they're awesome you like shooting
them
yeah a lot of fun go to shoot some skeet
or whatever have you done that have you
skate shot yes and it's a blast it's
awesome what are you doing have you done
skate have you done clay
clay pigeons yeah pigeons play pidgeon
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've
done that thanks for closing that please
close your eyes you're hearing an awful
scraping sound jealous of me he really
is jealous he doesn't even want me
i mean i think i remember being naively
optimistic that when we were making the
episode and we were calling out sort of
all the problems with mass shootings and
things at the time a little bit and the
problems with gun violence in our
country
thinking that like well but it will get
better you know that like yeah we'll
have this sort of
snarky social commentary in our show but
you know by the you know in 10 years or
so we'll get past some of this so
i'm displeased you know if you're asking
my full opinion with guns which is like
it's crazy yeah i think the problem is
that we can't acknowledge that there's a
problem which is just nuts which is just
nuts
and then you know i think the other
thing that people hide behind they say
well it's a mental health issue well
sure also yes also that we can do two
things
let's do two things at once let's work
on both we definitely hit this issue
much harder in the uh gun fever two
still next which we'll which we'll get
to in a long time from now yeah when the
[ __ ] did we do that season seven or
eight no idea oh yeah i don't remember
either they do start to blend in
quite a bit i could name probably season
again not having seen them for a decade
i could still
name all the episodes from one two and
three maybe even four and then i'm lost
that's it and then i'm lost all the way
up until yeah because they just kind of
start to blend together
rob what's your take on guns let's get
real for a minute here
you know we can't just
do the episodes about these heavy topics
and just totally avoid them i think it's
a complicated issue i have a firearm
myself i have a firearm i have a handgun
in my house but i keep locked in the
safe
i enjoy shooting the gun it's like a
pistola like a little yeah like a little
like a little pistola it's kind of safer
yeah
you died it's like the lead poisoning
yeah
you talk about pistols or you used to
talk about pistols a lot what is it i
don't know what it is well i'm i don't
know i i might i might be making it up
but like at the time you know like the
little tiny gun that like can fit in the
pocket
like a little derringer like a
gentleman's gun yeah
like where the madams used to keep him
in their purse right yeah like like the
man who you don't think has a gun then
suddenly he shot you and he's like
surprised i had a gun all along like
that kind of gun
well what else guys i mean uh what else
i can't be the only one asking questions
no that's no i know
i didn't sign up to be the host of this
[ __ ] show
we won nor did we
do this
i'm sure because i'm the only one
keeping the goddamn thing on track yeah
i
you hate the gum smacking but you love
that from danny absolutely oh well
that's what but that's what i love about
it is that it's so [ __ ] obnoxious so
if you make a joke about it i mean my
favorite joke in in the pilot that we
did which nobody ever saw boldly going
nowhere
what's the fact that
actor chad coleman who played uh the
character cobalt in the pilot um who
plays z on it's always sunny in
philadelphia was the security officer on
the spaceship that the show took place
on and he had put someone in the brig
because they were chewing their gum too
loudly yeah that whole sequence makes me
laugh super hard and it's fantastic he's
always fantastic yeah he's like giving
my character a tour around the ship and
he sees the guy and he's like well
what's this guy in for and he's like all
i was doing was chewing gum
yeah and she's not going to do the
action yeah but you were smacking it
driving everybody crazy
it's like the best delivery ever his
eyes bulging out driving everybody crazy
uh do you remember who played the kid in
the rig it was eric zimmerman our
assistant our assistant at the time
that's right yeah hey can you do your
cch pounder invitation because that's a
classic yeah what's up yeah let's see um
goddammit dutch whatever errands do you
have us running for the d.a
now there's going to be a large portion
of our audience that doesn't know cch
boundary and i suggest seek that woman
out watch an episode of the shield which
is fantastic she's fantastic i can
assure you that is a perfect well i
think the one in the episode that i did
was probably a little bit closer just
because i think i'd warmed up i think
i'd studied i think it was a little
fresher in my head yeah yeah i remember
when we
i must have been season one or season
two i got gifted from fx the shield
which is kind of a funny gift to be like
here's here's our show here's our show
right right but it turned out to be a
great gift because i watched them all
and that show was fantastic yes i wonder
if they have a podcast that show blew my
[ __ ] mind the first time when i saw
that pilot i was like
man this show looks like [ __ ] and it's
so good yeah yeah so you know kenny so
the first time i met kenny was at a
party kenny who the guy that plays lim
i can't remember the show
i knew i liked it but i don't remember
the guy who barely got any [ __ ] lines
he's very affable he's not blonde hair
yeah blonde hair not bad
yeah not walton goggins yeah okay yeah
i mean within three minutes of the
conversation he was like do you want to
arm wrestle oh and i was like where was
this yeah where was this this was
actually had john landgraf's house for
like a christmas party john landgraf
guys is the president of fx yes i had
just smoked i don't know a thousand
cigarettes with walton goggins because i
was still smoking cigarettes that's how
long ago this was season two
and he was like hey do you wanna um arm
wrestle okay and i was like i just met
him and i was like why
uh no no no i don't wanna arm wrestle i
i thought he was joking at first and he
was like oh man all right cool like was
he drunk nah and i was like what's what
why and he's like i just
i just arm wrestle everybody like this
is kind of my thing and i was like oh oh
okay well maybe later and then he then
he proceeded to tell me how he was the
arm wrestling champion of the pacific
northwest so he would have broken your
arm oh yeah yeah i think he just wanted
to but he's a very sweet man yeah and
then eventually i did arm wrestle him
because he very clearly wanted to yeah
but he started me he was like you can
start all the way and i had like started
all the way down and i still got you
where he was an inch off the table oh
yeah i mean he would rip my arm over
straight
do you get so you guys remember the
movie the stallone movie over the top of
course and there's that you guys
remember that that montage sequence at
the end where it's the final competition
and everybody's doing there is a moment
in that montage of arm wrestling bouts
where a guy's arm clearly [ __ ] snaps
in half
and it's just it's real quick you see
the guy you see his arm you see him
wince and it cuts away and the sequence
keeps going and i think that you know
they were just like well that guy lost
you know is the idea behind the sequence
in the film but if you're watching even
slightly closely enough you see the
guy's [ __ ] arm snapping now how
quickly did the a.d you know cut
this is a callback to this call back in
the first episode because hey man the
guy's arm is broken if he get the scene
if he knew that it was a montage
sequence and that the point of the
sequence was for that guy to lose
then i would argue that he could call
cut very very quickly because it's not
like the guy had dialogue
you know if he doesn't matter with a
broken arm
it's not going to bleed out right
you could shoot for a while it depends
on how tough you are yeah i mean those
mma guys
he kept fighting yeah his arm's dangling
i saw a guy there's a guy whose arm was
broken and he punched the guy with the
broken arm and knocked the other guy
out the rich
franklin way oh my god happened for real
that's outrageous it broke his arm yeah
and then knocked the guy out i tell you
what i'm not that tough tell you what
you get a gun you don't need to do that
oh god no jesus christ i can't it's
funny that he that oh that actually made
me cringe that scared you that's it it
did it's there it was sarcasm it's edgy
it's very edgy edgy humor very edgy
humor yeah but it got me that but that
sent like a surge of uncomfortableness
through fear yeah the thing about god
well because it's so it [ __ ] people
or people are crazy people are [ __ ]
crazy and they're shooting each other
back to the mental health issue it's
it's
and
what the hell is going on two for one
can we work on both two wars
two issues two issues yeah
at the same time guns yeah
i don't know i got you know my theory on
all that is uh honestly goes back it's
just an evolution thing
we have not had
time
to evolve into the kinds of creatures
who all of us can actually conform to
the rules of society look
before when we were just tribes of
people and we had to defend our tribe
you want the [ __ ] maniac who's whose
bloodlust will allow him to slaughter
everybody and anyone who comes near the
tribe or
that guy or her sure sure but let's you
know let's be honest
but you you want a psychopath and you're
trying so in other words i'm saying
there you know there was a a use for
that guy yes you know even 5 000 years
ago to have a [ __ ] a full-fledged
maniac in your tribe who's just fearless
and [ __ ] insane who will slaughter
and kill anyone and everyone who even
comes i mean it's like you know those
guys they just like just give me
something to kill
now we've we're telling that guy's
ancestors like you can't kill anybody
and they're like
and then you sit him down in a [ __ ]
desk chair in an office and have him
stare at a computer and think that he's
not eventually gonna kill somebody by
the way that guy can still go join the
military if that person wants and
practice their killing techniques and
and become a weapon and go on
clandestine missions around the world
whatever it is but hopefully you can
channel it and you you're you're taking
out the right people though but you have
other systems at play here right all of
a sudden you have uh commerce coming
into the mix right so we're not we're
out of the feudal system in terms of
like that maniac is now guarding the
castle with his bunch of people and now
it's like well we have these weapons
we've had we'll have this weapons race
now we have these the technology that we
make guns readily available but now
we're gonna sell them now we're gonna
make money off selling guns and guess
what we're gonna we're gonna market them
to people and we're gonna sell them and
then now they're everywhere so it's all
these things it's all this thing man you
guys are pitching the movie fight club
what yes right now megan
that's fight club right what glenn and
charlie justice doesn't just describe
his fight club never seen him just go
back and go check it out no you're
you're right that movie is about soap
that wasn't so it's about a superman
that's about a soap maker who beats
people and brad pitts and meatloaf and
jared leto's
face oh meatloaf i forgot meatloaf was
it yeah milo's actually great in that
moment oh man yeah
everyone is cause it was fincher and you
made them do like 900 ticks each and
then you're going
can't get one good take out of 900 then
you got to recast the accuracy right
that's why brad pitt changed what every
actor wanted to look like
with that [ __ ] movie when he took his
shirt off in that basement and you saw
that torso
every single actor went well
that's the new standard and it's uh
practically unreachable and uh and it's
just i love picturing you in the theater
being like well that's the new standard
what's that getting up and walking out
well guys so standard every
buddies and being like well guys that's
the new standard you know yeah
oh god but it was he i mean i was like
you are
just
it's just lighting and makeup
genetics and diet i mean he you know
he's
hard for that but he's just a beautiful
human he's gorgeous gorgeous absolutely
gorgeous absolutely gorgeous gorgeous
cut that got that cut that got that why
um no i'm kidding uh i don't care
i love him i want to be him yeah oh yeah
um
oh brad i looked really lonely that time
we saw him here on the fox thought
didn't he he was sitting by himself sure
he's fine
yeah i think he's all right sure he's
mine yeah he's all right
he's all right don't worry about brad
pitt you know what you're worried about
brad pitt no i'm not i'm worried about
him no no he's doing okay i'm sure he's
doing let's have him on the show let's
see maybe he'll tell somebody guess what
surprise guests he's here brad what do
you have to say
well that sums that up there's a man
you guys have a lot of celebrity friends
yeah yeah
yeah do you feel like you have a lot of
like big celebrity friends like outside
like i'm friendly with many people who
are celebrities well here's the but do i
do i have a lot of celebrity friends
here's what the smattering the grossest
game i don't that we've ever played uh
that's actually really really funny and
it's just gross
no
no no no no
great
that was pretty gross
uh no is everybody flipped through your
phone and who has the most celebrity
phone numbers in your contacts is the
growth that's the hilarious game you can
possibly play but also really really fun
bob you hang out with a rock a lot is
this true yeah yeah i see the rock quite
a bit
um
you guys are just talking about an a
that's not just an actual rock that you
talk to right like just a rock that's in
your garden that you talk to hey rock
you know what it is kind of the rocks
like call me dwayne i was thinking about
this in terms of celebrity pals
you're very good friends now with like
chase utterly you're like best friends
and i was thinking about that joke that
we had where you write him the letter
which we wrote before you knew chase you
didn't know him at all right then we
just wrote that joke in and then
and then you got what you wanted and
then we'd be well he made a response
video didn't he yeah isn't that what and
then how the whole thing kind of started
yeah that's between you and chase and
yeah he responded to it and then we got
him on the show and then we just became
friends
our wives became really good friends and
now we're and he but it also helped that
he moved to california you do have
friends
who me yeah
i do but i don't like uh you don't see
what i'm looking for people oh yeah yeah
i i don't uh i prefer to be my myself
i'm
actually quite introverted believe it or
not even though i'm very loud on this
podcast well let's
rewind back to that first minute and a
half of this podcast i don't see an
introvert actually i do maybe i do i see
an introvert who's ready to explode at
any moment oh yeah well i'm very angry i
didn't say i wasn't angry i'm just
saying i'm introverted i really am to a
dangerous degree like if i had
absolutely nothing to do and no wife and
children i would i would spend weeks at
a time never leaving my house absolutely
and never talking to a single [ __ ]
person and then i'd come out of it like
oh my god that was awful
but then i would do it again the next
chance i got i would do it again anytime
my wife goes out of town with my kids i
i spend the whole [ __ ] time in my
house doing nothing
because i love it i love it i just want
to be left alone now you charlie you
wrote something down were you writing
you were doing guys
i got a little boarded your little shape
yeah he draws this
i thought for a second you were taking
notes oh god do you remember all the
great like stuff that charlie used to do
when we'd be sitting in the edit all
three of us before phones before phones
yeah because now you can pick up your
phone where you you would do
we would pick we he'd just like pick up
a magazine
phones existed but before smartphones
smartphones but charlie would pick
charlie by the way is a very
talented man in almost every facet of uh
artistry oh go on no
it's true but like you would pick up
magazines and you would like find a
picture of somebody and then you would
like doodle on the person's body and
face to turn them into a totally
different human being yes i remember
thinking that is the funniest [ __ ] oh
you do it with head shots too heads up
like audition hedging that is a jimmy
simpson technique so jimmy simpson and i
used to do that to our own headshots
like we have a pile of useless head
shots and we gotta we mastered like a
racing you can erase them you can erase
the ink right yeah you're like wow i can
erase my eyebrows and erase my eyes
and jimmy would sometimes cut in
different eyes from like a magazine
full season you guys did this in the in
the editing room it was the funniest
[ __ ] thing to me you loved it i felt
so cute
jimmy was a master
i was okay i was okay we got to have
jimmy on the podcast that the man is i
love that man so much he is the fight
nobody that man makes me laugh so
[ __ ] hard he is so so so brilliant
guy also very good at like what anything
he wants to do he's like very good at
yeah and just a good dude just a good
dude yeah
yeah drinks a lot of strawberry yoo-hoo
still maybe i don't know
i don't know didn't have the best diet
back in the day that was a long time ago
so when i met mary elizabeth my wife and
uh we met in new york and we met outside
of a a play that i was doing and we all
hung out in a bar and she can't tell us
that story yeah i'll skip it because you
guys know it but anyway she was at my
apartment and she opened the fridge and
that night
uh the next morning pal wow
actually i left her because i had to go
do a recording for ifc that i'd
forgotten about and had you consummated
this the relationship already no i don't
think so we had a little bit of fun
anyway she opens she's
understandably thirsty hungry she opens
the fridge i'm living with jimmy simpson
the only thing that is there's only two
things
strawberry gogurt oh god that like jimmy
had bought
and
a yogurt a meat a hunk of like ground
beef
that had been shaped into a penis
why because jimmy and i are making a
funny video about a man who smashes his
penis off with a hammer
and we needed a fake penis
and uh you know that pretty much sums us
up that sealed the deal she was like i
gotta marry like this is the one this is
my guy this is the guy well that makes
perfect sense actually because her sense
of humor is just as twisted and strange
as yes yeah yeah yeah she's a very very
funny human being yes and your wife yeah
what else do i want to know it's 5 10.
so we've been talking about a little
over an hour here that's about podcast
well this is that that should be that
should be it that's the end
no that was impressive that was too
abruptly
you're the host
um
fine i'll be the host
well we've been singing the birds of war
and one of the things that we'd
forgotten
which was the lyrics which i think was
the best part of that song is that we're
singing about the fact that we're not
just birds
we're men we have muscles the whole song
is about clarifying that you're not just
a bird but that you're also a man you
also have the moment you have all the
best parts of a bird but also the best
parts of a man yes but we reiterate one
more time in the song but we're also mad
yeah right at the end of war yeah well
maybe we'll sing it for you guys
sometime and get the lyrics right
we'll do it around the season where we
uh do that do that about six years from
now yep oh god oh god stick with us guys
i promise it's only gonna get better
from here grasshoppers spooky or not
spooky
you